what can we expect for season three
i don't know
isn't it hot nicola what a moment
bridgerton season two finally here how
excited are you and what would you tease
for the fans that they're gonna get i am
so excited i mean it feels like it's
always nice to get to this point when
you're like it's almost ready to share
the world's like your baby and you're
like here it is i hope you love it as
much as i love it and it's it's really
funny because we have you know the
advantage of this being based in a book
series so we know that this is a book
that the book fans are obsessed with and
have really wanted to get to this story
of kate and anthony so it just feels
like oh we're going in you know with the
winner already it's great she's
threatening my family pen
i should get rid of these if the queen
discovers i have all of these in my
possession then it will only make me
appear that much more guilty but you are
not guilty l
now we really see this cat and mouse
game between penelope and eloise and
i just wondered how much fun that was
for you and claudia to play because
she's told me you two are quite good
friends we're really good friends and
it's amazing and yeah playing it with
her she's just such a fantastic actor
and she's just a pleasure to be around
as well so it just makes the days on set
which can be super long days it makes
them just easy and fun but also i think
a lot of it this time because you know
penelope's lady whistle down you are
very much aware of when she's not
telling the truth and i
i'm honest to a fault so i found it
really like uncomfortable so when
penelope's outright talking at eloise
about lady whistle down i was like
sweating i was like and they call cut
and i'd go oh that didn't feel good
that felt pretty bad actually by the way
speaking of sweating i mean you guys
wear the corsets and the wigs and
everything what are some tips you would
you've now learned heading into season
two all of you about just like how to
perform in these costumes and like like
do you put on extra deodorant do you do
shallow breaths what do you do
i think some people like to take them
off at lunchtime i would advise against
that because it's like i would equate it
to you know sometimes when you're at a
party and your high heel starts hurting
and when you take it off then you can't
you can't get your foot back in it it's
essentially the same thing so i'm like
just bare with the corset just stay in
it i bring a pillow with me all the time
so that i can sort of prop myself up
like this
so you don't ruin the hair i've sort of
found ways to sit in my trailer that's
not
it's just yeah tricks of the trade you
learn as you go along
is there anything you took home from set
with you
i took home i have a dance cards and
they sometimes yeah the props guys they
don't i ask i try not to steal them i
have those but not too much i feel like
in season three i'm gonna go in and
start clearing out because people ask
all the time i'm like i've got barely
anything i need to keep my place out
um now shonda just told me we're going
out of order we're mixing things up so
what can we expect for season three is
it a story of penelope and colin
i don't know
i did not know she said that i said i
just got hot i just got hot
we end it with this big fight and it
makes me want more from eloise from
penelope from colin there's a
heartbreaking moment where penelope
hears colin talking about her you're
courting the girl bridgette
ah are you mad i would never dream of
courting penalty featherington not in
your wildest fantasies fife
it's a bit it's it's a big one and
that's something from penelope and
colin's book that happens you know when
they're quite young and she hears some
sort of go yeah i would never i would
never date her it's not going to happen
but um luke newton and i luca faced
colin we spoke to chris van dusen the
show runner and we were like you know
where's it going what's going to happen
he sort of said and we took that moment
in and we put it in we took it out all
this and i i always felt like it was
important to put it in because penelope
just thinks colin's perfect and she's
gonna realize he's not perfect he's just
human okay so colin for season three
what
sips or juice what do you know what have
you been told
season three you know i genuinely
haven't asked very much because
it's
it's when the seasons are happening it's
so all-encompassing it takes over your
world that i really wanted to get season
two out there and celebrate it and let
it have its moment before i start
because it it just takes over your life
it takes over your life so i'm like so
i'm waiting i don't know maybe like a
week after season one is out there in
the world
then okay well knowing how season two
ends what do you want for penelope i
will say i want penelope to have a
steamy scene i want her to have an
intimate moment i mean that's the thing
about being commissioned for four
seasons i know the love story is coming
so i'm like but then it's like sort of
terrifying and because i know it's luke
and i've known liv now for like three
years that we joke in the beginning we
joked about it we're like oh it's so
funny it's you know it's going to be ha
ha
like those kind of scenes and then now
it's like becoming more real by the day
and we're like oh okay oh god um
it's it's so scary so scary but i do
yeah i do want her to find love and i
don't want her to stop writing whistle
down i want her to have everything why
don't you have everything have you read
all the books
i've read so i've read them i read book
four first it's kind of colin's book and
then i read book one and two i haven't
read three yet i ended my friendship
with theo because of you
one of the only good things in my life
all because of
self-serving manipulation you have no
idea how horrible it felt to keep this
from you
so tell the fans give the fans some hope
or maybe not can eloise and penelope
recover from this fight what will happen
they have to get over they have to
because i would break my heart also i
think you know in deep lifelong
friendships there are moments like that
where you do fight and you've just got
to you know you've got to just learn to
grow and get over but i think penelope's
got so apologizing to do i think she's
apologizing today last question give me
your favorite stage direction from the
script claudia told me there are some
hilarious ones like some af what's your
favorite one the funniest ones i have to
say are like the the sexy scenes
um because betsy beers who is a
legendary executive at chandelaine she
um
she reads them and she gives her
everything
so i i i want to say it's a little too
explicit you can imagine what it's like
sitting in a room just a bunch of tables
and someone reading out
things say it nicola please say it we'll
believe it
she reads it she's like here she's like
she reads it at speed she's like and
he's kissing her and it's amazing and
they're in this library and he's going
he's going down and he's out of that and
you're like it's all kind of like that
i can't remember verbatim but it's the
vibe that's the vibe
[Music]
you